Now, I want you to help me think about all the abstractions that sit between
these two extremes, Google Earth application that makes
magic happen on the screen and the solid-state
physics the electrons and holes enshrine in
your computer system. What are all the abstractions
that sit between these two extremes? What I want you to do in this quiz is
to name as many abstractions as you can between these two extremes
that I am showing you. To make room for you, let me clear
some space. I put a box now for your answer. To give you
an idea of what is expected in this question,
as an answer, let me start you off with naming the abstraction
that sits right on top of the electrons and holes. This is of course your solid
state physics. And you rain in all the
randomness in the movement of the electrons and holes
in the solid-state physics, with this abstraction called
transistor. The transistor is akin to an on-off
switch. Now, what I want you to do is fill the rest of the box with all
the other abstractions that sits above transistors,
all the way up to the application.